coach G I want to ask you a little bit
about the history of step because I
think we have to put in a context the
fact that blessing saw for the first
time in a historically black college I
think it's important can you talk a
little talk to us a little bit about
where step comes from and what its
historical roots are hello everyone I'm
coach T step came from Africa and it
came to America thank you sir thank you
and it came to America through the
transatlantic slave trade and then it
was made popular through black Greek
fraternities sororities community
schools churches youth groups and it's a
really predominant in the
african-american community and hopefully
with this movie it will be more
mainstream people we doing it all over
and it's already done all over the world
but again it's really predominant
african-american community step is
making music with your body or
percussion with your body clapping
stomping shouting spoken word
cheerleading moves gymnastics stomping
petting parts of your bodies literally
making music with your body Amanda I
think it's fair to say that almost every
documentary filmmaker does not end up
making the film that he or she first
imagines they're going to tell and I
think that's absolutely the case with
this so before we talk about the movie
that you ended up making I want to talk
about your family's history to the
school history with the school and how
that led to the first iteration of what
you were going to make about the set so
I'm I'm a Broadway producer in my other
life and I make musicals and plays on
Broadway and on the side of my Broadway
career I started making shorts about
first-generation students going to
college and girls education and I just
was always inspired when I told the
story in short form of a first
generation student going to college and
what that meant for their family and I
became involved with a group of schools
called the young women's leadership
school to New York which are five
all-girls public schools six through
twelfth grade with a hundred percent
graduation rate and I was just blown
away by these schools I am born and
raised in Baltimore
my mom's born and raised in Baltimore
has been an activists there my whole
life for women and girls I grew up with
a domestic violence hotline being run
from my dining room table so I had the
kind of mother that I could suggest
maybe she should replicate
to school like these schools I was
working with in Baltimore and she did
and she recruited her daughter to make
films for her and I did so I met these
young ladies when they were 11 years old
and I started making shorts just to
promote the school and promote the good
work that everyone was doing there and I
knew that the step team had started what
I wasn't familiar with staff it wasn't
something that was a part of my culture
growing up it didn't know about the rich
history coming from Africa I didn't know
about it being a collegiate sport now in
North America but in the 8th grade I was
filming blessing for another project in
New York we were she was actually
interviewing sherrilyn Ifill at the ACLU
and she looked at me and she said you
know the next time you come to school
with cameras you really need to come
film our step team and I said okay
because I was always drawn to blessing
you know she kind of linked her arm with
mine when she was 11 and said you're a
Broadway producer I'm going to be on
Broadway and I believed her and I just
remember walking in and my heart stopped
beating because of every stomp with
every clap with every breath they were
expressing themselves and that's what
happens in a great musical you know in a
great musical a character can't speak
anymore so they sing to express their
fears and their hopes and their dreams
and that's what they were doing and I
knew them well enough at that point to
know that I saw every range of girl on
that team and that there was a lot of
stories that needed to be told well I
think the story that you were going to
tell the stories that you were involved
in changed dramatically when Freddie
gray was murdered so I want to ask you
how your approach to this story changed
after his death and what the film what
direction the film went into after he
was killed
well we were already filming Freddie
gray was killed in their junior year in
April of their junior year and it was a
rough year for the step team blessin had
a rough year at school academically and
through a lot of different circumstances
ended getting kicked off the team and it
was a real gut punch for all of us
because she was the heart
in Seoul and the captain and founder of
the team and I watched these young women
pull her back in and I watched the
school use step to pull her back in and
it was incredible and I thought this is
going to be amazing
they are the founding class of this
school and they are going to be the
first in their families to go to college
we always when I met with all the
families and all the girls in the ninth
grade to talk about making a documentary
I said let's change the conversation
about Baltimore with these young women
in the step team and then when Freddie
gray was killed I just knew that that
was the start of the story that was the
beginning that was the jumping-off point
and in a musical you know you always
have to have a ticking clock you always
have to have something Universal that
everyone can relate to and so all my
footage that I had filmed from 9th
through 11th grade I put to the side and
I created a trailer that opened just
like the movie opened a three minute
trailer with Freddie gray when I saw
that mom go into the riot and pull out
her son and hit him over the head I was
like those are my mother's on the step
team that's my Isha she would do that
and I I just knew that that were there
that was the images that needed to start
and then we literally needed to see them
stamped out we needed to see the feet
come down so all I mean for us Freddie
Gray's death turned the flame up in all
of us and I think made these young gave
these young women and their families the
courage and the strength to really tell
the story
coach gee and the girls when you're
talking about the way in which you can
take Freddie Gray's murder and make it
part of your step what were the
conversations that you had as a team and
as a teacher and what were the things
that you wanted to bring to light not
just through performance but through
rehearsal and talking about his death
that you think were important so coach
she wanted you start and we'll talk to
the girls as well for me what was
important was for them to realize this
is a wonderful magical place but it's a
very small charter school Baltimore
filled with so many people who love them
and believe in them and tell them that
the sky's the limit that's very true
there's so many people who are going to
trip you up in the way of trying to
reach the sky we're going to pull you
back and as young black women you know
we have it twice as hard and people
don't you don't walk into a room and
people
actually be equally as adequate as they
are and that's just a reality so I
wanted them to be realistic about what
is out there in the real world they were
always taught to be self advocates they
were always taught to stand up for
themselves and have confidence and all
of those things but my conversation was
how do you feel about this more
social-emotional how do you feel about
what happened where were you what were
you doing what were you thinking what
was going through your mind when we did
that routine for black lives matters it
was a Baltimore routine and a lot of
also more stuff competition and a lot of
competitions give you guidelines as to
what you can make the theme and the
first thing that came to my mind was it
was almost a year after Freddie gray
died and I was like oh definitely I'm
gonna do black lives matters because
after Freddie gray was murdered somebody
else was murdered and then somebody else
was murdered so these are things that I
wanted them to understand as young black
women when you walk out of these doors
it could be you it could be me it could
be any of you and I think that it was
important for me to change the
conversation about black lives matters
to not being a hateful thing or saying
that other lives don't matter because
that's not what that statement is about
it's about the fact that everyone has
children and no one wants to bury their
child and the reality is if these young
girls going to a charter school that's
college prep are putting their hands up
and saying don't shoot that's exactly
what these young men and women who are
victims of these crimes of these
atrocities that's that's exactly what
happened to them so if you can imagine
them in that place then you can think
like oh this could be my child you have
that empathy empathy to think this could
be my child that's beautifully set
lesson Cory and Caleb what do you think
about what your coach just said about
the ways in which you can use step to
tell a story and come together and
express something that you're feeling
and share it with a bigger audience
I completely agree um let me start off
in sixth grade there was just something
fun to do it looked cool and we really
liked the costumes and makeup and stuff
but over the years it really started to
become so
much more than just entertainment and I
think that's something that's really
important that we appreciate closely for
because she helped us to you know kind
of cross over from just entertaining to
also educating people because there are
people who don't understand where we
come from or who don't understand the
things that we go through the
adversities that we face on a daily
basis whether those be social or
political or academic or with our
families and really step is really just
that platform for us to share our
experiences I agree with Cory Cory
actually a lot of coaches well we've had
a lot of coaches in their focus was
entertainment and no one ever really
taught us how to educate when we step
and mostly we learnt that people listen
to you when you're with a group and
you're loud and you're stomping and
you're clapping and you have fun while
you're doing it and I think that when
you're educating you should have fun
while you're doing it and make sure that
you have a purpose Laura I want to ask a
little bit about how you incorporate a
smiie Annie I'm not I'm going to ask you
one thing about incorporating music into
we're into a story in which music and
rhythm to figure so prominently when
you're working with Raphael Saadiq and
trying to figure out how you're going to
place music in this you obviously pun
intended don't want to step on the
stepping so what do you look for how
does music accentuate what is already an
incredibly emotional story what is the
texture and depth that it can give a
documentary like this well they're
heroes so I think that the first thing
to do is to write music that's heroic
but intimate and that it's a it's a
small story about everyday heroes but of
course it's a huge story so I think that
was the the challenge and and the goal
of it and also just to stay out of the
way yeah which is not my not me really
you know I'm a kind of get in the way
kind of gal but with Amanda I think that
was the discipline here stay out of the
way set up the sort of the theatricality
of it come into play I mean important
montages is the is the pyramid montage
and then of course the song at the end
those are those are the places where
where we were allowed to shine musically
and every place else we're kind of like
don't do too much by the way I just want
to say I've done a lot of panels here I
think it's the first thing I've done
with six women up yeah so and I think
that's amazing because I also think this
is a story about women I think it's a
story about moms and I think we should
give a shout out to all the moms yeah
you guys thank you so much for coming
out